è
bella a tutti i ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo nuovo video che è partito strano
per farti chandon ha fatto niente ho
schiacciato registra giorno devo posso
schiacciare schiaccio qua
sì però stai calmo cortesia o sbagliato
sui giusti cioè questo che carica
ma bellissimo e io sono utili a quelli
solo col mouse che ti schiaccio col
mouse sono morto che è successo sul
pavimento fatto di merda o c'è un frigo
c'è un tappezzano il frigo perde acqua
ragazzi mi dovete spiegare questo gioco
non sa ancora il lo abbia avviato niente
partito subito il che è molto strano
trovato preso la propria intervento a
breve quindi un punta e clicca dove a
prof righi non è che mi diventa rosso il
cursore quando lo fare qualcosa perché
qua non è rosso mai sinistra
c'è la porta c'era una porta nascondo
l'avevo vista mai ovviamente la che
compare solo al momento in cui ti
avvicini poi molti sono a destra
sinistra bene
apriamo tipo little big planet ma non è
proprio planet misto gioco
è una pace una lampadina addetti non io
guarda visto la roba che sta sul succoso
non lo spiace legge non direi la leva
con tanta semplicità però vabbè facciamo
s'è spaccata la luce e fin qua
[Musica]
va bene io vado a lanciano non so cosa
fosse fatto ciò anche perché no perché
mi dare allo stato qualcuno che posso
fare ancora qualcosa no quindi diventa
rosso un po a caso il corso ora veniamo
a sinistra l'ex gal
hai un ascensore bellissimo siamo al
quinto questo quindi andiamo al sesto no
anche hans che se qualcuno qualcuno ha
aperto non
hanno la porta qua il quarto è chiusa
c'è una destra
non c'è con sé una mano c'è un fiocco
e un fiocco devo tagliarlo non si sa mai
puoi anche lodarlo con le mani e non è
che madonna che ha impedito che
mostrarono forbici per tagliare le
forbici italiano ragazzi per tagliare il
fiocco perché se no
ho capito mi che mettendo nelle carte
dei filati chiudila va beh la madonna
alzarvi casa in siberia ok ok
piano 2 o delle scarpe delle scatole che
con per niente male piano 2
[Musica]
la bottiglia edition armadio l'armadio
va bene la bottiglia
che li mette riesca a mettere questa
roba
non ho capito ma con le scarpe
sono delle rose con delle spine tutto
chiaro un gioco che comunque è facile da
comprendere nel senso che non vedo c'è
tutto la linea eco giocherà pokémon
perfetto o una bottiglia credo che con
questa di poter di poter tagliare fiocco
no allora rovi ci fa andare game
andiamo ai 44 al fioccano
con questa rispetto a ieri abbiamo la
buona e la
giacchetti che fa freddo
mettiamo la giacchetta e così possiamo
andare l'altro posto poi c'è
qualcos'altro
il fatto che comunque il fatto che
l'ascensore si apre in casa è una cosa
che mi ha sempre inquietato ragazzi non
vivrei mai una casa con l'ascensore che
si apre in casa mai mai è un'ansia
terribile a verona 7 apribile
bruttissimo come due come chiacchiera la
roba da quando
stando allo svizzero
yes
ciapa la valigia me ne vado a dubai per
quanto ci alle rose ma cosa te ne fai
prova di già
sto camminando sulla val i non è un buon
segno questo cosa devo fare questa
valigia qua
c'è un quadro di un tizio che sembro io
c'è una tesi a quei capelli lunghi
con la mia stessa mai giacca tra l'altro
non è veloce le maniche corte questo
sono un pessimo osservatorio me ne posso
andare le palle no rimango qua
dovevo prendere la bataille mi dovevo
usare la valigia come ma dai ma che ci
sarebbe mai arrivato
mi chiama per caso uno scoperto tra
l'altro per tutto sto portello per
andare a sostituire la lampadina ma voi
siete pazzi per avere tutto sto casino
per sostituire alla maria di merda va
bene ecco perché me la dava ancora
selezionabile va dal [ __ ] adesso cade
mister bean
simbolo ma non ai che ansia s'è riaperta
la porta va bene
sono con la valigia nella stanza
dell'inizio ho messo la giacchetta
ci sarà il frico lì prima dove frigo
che pensa fiori un vestito
o se
o'shea
ehi
tesoro successo c'è questa sta con un
altro eletto io tutto sto casino per
prenderle dire
sto facendo non fare niente
no no no è la madonna parliamone ma che
cazzo è
oddio
da una vera mi sembra
cosa sta diventando sto gioco sa di dio
no
ma co
cosa su cosa ho visto
cosa ho visto
ma
ma era un sogno qualcosa cioè non capire
è un sogno certo ma cosa sto vedendo e
le ripartire il battito lo è un loop la
ragazzi ma di che parliamo non sto
capendo è un loop ripartito da zero
tutto vero quello che ho visto mi sarei
mai aspettato dal finale ma che vaghe ma
poi la cosa non ho capito nel senso che
tu puoi giocare per cambiare il finale
nel perché te lo fa rifare perché se fai
determinate cose poi cambiare il finale
cos'è ragazzi 6 conoscete società o
fatemelo sapere perché io non la
sostanza però avere ragazzi questo è
l'amore comunque non mi aspettavo niente
del genere ma proprio più certo mappa
per niente fatemi sapere come dire
pensate ci vediamo al prossimo episodio
di ormai proceduto loro quindi avete sky
canale tutta roba psichedelica strana di
giochi che ci stanno su internet che
rischi che gli piace e ricicliamo e
sempre al prossimo video ragazzi
[Musica]